hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
since we last looked at we work the
founder of the company has been pushed
out the investors have found a
replacement and Softbank
has come in to save the day with an
eight billion dollar bailout but six
months on a global pandemic sees we work
offices empty and a company in a very
ugly legal battle with the investment
fund that was meant to be at Savior we
work is far from out of the woods and
their founder Adam Newman drove them on
a road paved by soft banks millions but
will they be able to find a way out into
the light let's take a look as discussed
in the previous video we work was far
from what it pretended to be it
portrayed itself as a Silicon Valley
tech startup like Amazon or Google but
instead it was a company that owned
solid office space plain and simple
its valuations were extremely
disproportionate compared to his
competitors and their founder Adam
Newman well he was controversial to say
the least
in the last video we pondered what would
happen if we work a company that was
burning cash at a record pace found
itself in the middle of a recession what
was going to happen when people stopped
renting their office space well that day
has come and we find ourselves in the
middle of a global pandemic and we work
finds itself with empty offices
softbank's famous 100 billion dollar
vision fund saw a seventeen point seven
billion dollar loss last fiscal year
mainly due to its unfortunate
investments in uber and we work Softbank
led by my CEO she son has invested
eighteen point five billion dollars in
total in we work in just a year we work
saw its valuation go from forty seven
billion down to a mere two point nine
billion son has done some hard
reflecting and he says that it was
foolish to invest in the first place now
son is pulling back three billion
dollars worth of Baelor money money that
Softbank agreed to pay we work to keep
the ailing investment afloat this money
was part of an eight billion dollar
bailout agreement that would be an
injection that we work desperately
needed in retaliation we work launched a
lawsuit against soft bank for backing
out of the agreement it's a messy fight
to have with your biggest investor but
maybe we work has no other choice with
the pandemic rendering their office
space obsolete
one person who was very interested in
progressing the lawsuit is co-founder
and former CEO Adam Newman would the
bailout the former CEO who was kicked
out of the company was set to make a
whopping nine hundred and seventy
million dollars from selling his we work
stock directly to Softbank Adam has
launched his own lawsuit against soft
bank and is now looking to merge his
lawsuit with the suit filed by the we
work board dramatic turn taking place in
the we work saga founder and former CEO
Adam Newman now suing the company's
biggest investor soft bank was to
control the company hey guys I'll ask
you both this I mean the idea that Adam
Newman is bringing this doesn't hey does
he just have no shame he doesn't even
recognize how ridiculous it looks to be
arguing about how he didn't walk away
with an additional billion dollars we're
going to have to see how this plays out
but it will be interesting to see if
Newman who was once worth 14 billion can
regain his billionaire status for pretty
much everyone on earth the pandemic was
unforeseen and it makes Softbank
reconsidering their deal perhaps the
least of weworks concerns tall towers
consumed face taller financial problems
the majestic skyscrapers of New York
City to the real estate trophies in Los
Angeles the coronavirus threatens to do
to office rentals what online shopping
did to malls as governments around the
world put restrictions in place the we
work offices sit quietly open agreements
between we work and their customers mean
that they can cancel at the end of the
month if they signed a month-to-month
membership
however for longer term agreements we
work is still insisting on charging
despite it being against government
advice to go into some of these offices
for example the New York locations have
been kept open and this is in the face
of lockdowns by its Governor Andrew
Cuomo we work even pays its staff and
extra hundred dollars a day if they come
in to keep the offices open despite at
least seven of these New York officers
having members that tested positive for
covert 19 we work is keeping itself open
by declaring itself an essential
business arguing that people need
grocery stores banks pharmacies and we
work
keeping the office space open is one
thing but then charging its customers
for something that they don't feel
completely safe to use is an entirely
different thing especially for a small
business this creates two problems for
we work one that is understandably a
large portion of its short-term
month-to-month customers will cancel
their membership at least for a few
months until things can get back to
normal
the second is we works action of
charging its long-term customers for
something that they can't actually
access has caused some anger angry
customers are bringing a class-action
lawsuit against the company this is
something that could hurt the company
severely if it gains enough traction in
the meantime in April we work collect at
70% of its normal rent and paid 80% of
the rent to the building owners so
that's not a bad situation for we work
yes they're still burning through cash
almost five hundred million dollars in
the first quarter of 2020 alone but can
they survive and what is the cost of
surviving and will people even return to
we work after all of this the big
question here apart from we were sketch
flow situation is simple what does the
future of work look like that's the
question that every business is asking
now there's a force globally shared
experience of working from home in this
many businesses are realizing that they
don't need an office for a lot of their
people technology has evolved so much
that many jobs that required a City
office a decade ago no longer do this
proof of concept that has happened on a
global scale is not one to look over
lightly sure many people will go back
into the office and many others won't
will these events reduce demand for
shared workspaces like we work the
future of work may be uncertain but the
future of we work is even more uncertain
only time will tell if they survive so
what do you guys think let me know in
the comments section below
if you want to watch the original video
on way work I'll leave that in the link
below
speaking of personalities I've also
recently done a video on the controversy
around the foundation of Twitter I've
been told via person working in Silicon
Valley that that video has ruffled some
feathers in the tech community over
there there's some hot debates going on
right now so definitely check out that
episode too if you haven't seen it
already okay so thanks for watching
my name is - gogo and you've been
watching cold fusion and I'll see you
again soon for the next video in the
next episode we'll take a deep look into
how money is created it's going to be
one of the most important videos I've
ever made
cheers guys have a good one cold fusion
[Music]